STEVE?
STEVE: GRIFF THANK YOU VERY MUCH
AS GRIFF JUST MENTIONED THREE
STATES STILL MOVING FORWARD WITH
TODAY’S PRIMARIES, DESPITE THE
COVID-19 CONCERNS INCLUDING
THE BIG STATE OF FLORIDA.
AINSLEY: HERE TO WEIGH IN IS
FLORIDA’S GOP SENATOR MARCO
RUBIO.
GOOD MORNING TO YOU, SENATORS.
>> GOOD MORNING.
AINSLEY: SO WHAT IS YOUR OPINION
, DO YOU THINK FLORIDA
SHOULD STILL CONTINUE TO HAVE
THE PRIMARY?
>> WELL I DON’T THINK IT’S FAIR
FOR ME TO PASS JUDGMENT ON IT
BECAUSE I WASN’T IN THOSE
MEETINGS WITH THE GOVERNOR
AND THE FLORIDA HEALTH AUTHORITY
TO REVIEW IT ALL, LOOK AT THE
DISRUPTION IT WOULD CREATE AND
MADE THAT DECISION.
AS YOU HEARD IN THAT CLIP THAT
JUST PLAYED THE GOVERNOR WAS
ADVISED BY THE LEADING HEALTH
AUTHORITY THAT HE RELIES ON,
THAT THEY THOUGHT THAT ACTIVITY
COULD GO ON WITHOUT IMPOSING A
PUBLIC HEALTH THREAT AND SO
ABSENT CONTRARY INFORMATION I’M
NOT GOING TO QUESTION THE
DECISION THAT THEY’VE MADE
AT THIS POINT IT’S HAPPENING AND
I DON’T WANT TO BE OUT THERE
DISCOURAGING PEOPLE FROM VOTING
AT THIS POINT.
BRIAN:  SO LET’S TALK ABOUT THE
RELIEF BILLS WORKING THEIR
WAY IN YOUR LAP TODAY, AND THEN
STEVEN MNUCHIN WILL INTRODUCE A
THIRD RELIEF BILL COMING YOUR
WAY.
FROM WHAT YOU’VE SEEN, WHAT
STANDS OUT THAT YOU LIKE AND
DON’T LIKE?
>> WELL FIRST OF ALL LET ME
JUST SAY THIS.
WE ARE NOT LIVING IN ORDINARY
TIMES.
THESE ARE NOT ORDINARY TIMES
THIS IS NOT A BUNCH OF
BUSINESSES WHO MADE A BAD
DECISION AND ARE LOOKING FOR THE
GOVERNMENT TO HELP THEM
OUT.
THIS IS A VIRUS THAT THREATENS
OUR ECONOMY BECAUSE IN ORDER TO
PREVENT THIS VIRUS FROM KILLING
A LOT OF PEOPLE, WE HAVE TO
FORCE PEOPLE OR  ASK PEOPLE TO
STAY HOME AND NOT GO TO
BUSINESSES, AND THE RESULT IS
PEOPLE ARE GOING TO LOSE THEIR
JOBS, BUSINESSES ARE GOING TO
CLOSE, AND WE’RE GOING TO HAVE
TO DO SOMETHING TO BUFFER THAT.
AND SO THAT’S THE WAY I WOULD
JUDGE EVERYTHING THAT WE’RE
TALKING ABOUT.
WHAT THE HOUSE PASSED IS NOT
PERFECT, BUT I THINK THE PRICE
IS IN ACTION AT THIS POINT IS
WAY TOO HIGH IN THE MEANTIME,
WHATEVER IS WRONG WITH THAT BILL
, WE WILL LOOK TO FIX AND A
BILL THAT WILL START HERE IN THE
SENATE THAT WE NEED TO PASS
VERY QUICKLY, AND THAT I THINK
WILL BE FOCUSED ON NUMBER ONE,
GETTING ALLOWING AIRLINES TO
CONTINUE TO OPERATE BECAUSE IF
WE SHUT DOWN THE AIRLINES, WE’RE
GOING TO HAVE A VERY DIFFERENT
COUNTRY WE WON’T BE ABLE TO MOVE
PEOPLE AROUND IMPORTANT TRIPS
THAT NEED TO HAPPEN FOR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND FOR NATIONAL SECURITY
AND SO FORTH, AND THE SECOND IS
WE NEED TO GET FUNDS WE NEED TO
GET LIQUIDITY INTO THE HANDS OF
SMALL BUSINESSES WHO ARE NOT
GOING TO BE ABLE TO MEET PAYROLL
AS REQUIRED UNDER THE PAID LEAVE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE HOUSE BILL,
AND ARE GOING TO STRUGGLE TO BE
AROUND FOR SIX, EIGHT, 12 WEEKS
FROM NOW, WHEN EVERYTHING SORT
OF SETTLES DOWN A LITTLE BIT AND
SO THAT’S THE PART THAT WE’RE
FOCUSED ON.
WE’VE GOT A PRETTY GOOD OUTLINE
THAT’S BIPARTISAN OBVIOUSLY WE
NEED TO HEAR FROM MORE COLLEAGUE
S BUT THAT’S THE PIECE
I’LL FOCUS ON AND WE NEED TO
MOVE ON THAT VERY VERY FAST.
STEVE: SENATOR YOU JUST SAID WE
DON’T HEAR MUCH THESE DAYS FROM
WASHINGTON AND THAT IS
BIPARTISAN.
IT SEEMS LIKE LAWMAKERS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE AISLES REALIZE THE
GRAVITY OF THIS PARTICULAR
GLOBAL PANDEMIC AND THEY ARE
PULLING OUT AS MANY STOPS AS IS
POSSIBLE BY WASHINGTON STANDARDS
>> YOU KNOW, MOST OF THE THINGS
WE DO AROUND HERE, DESPITE THE
FACT THAT WE’RE DRIVEN TO H
YPERBOLE, THE VAST MAJORITY OF
THINGS WE DO AREN’T GOING TO BE
REMEMBERED ON A LONGVIEW OF
HISTORY MAYBE NOT EVEN A YEAR
FROM NOW.
THIS IS WRITTEN ABOUT 100 YEARS
THIS IS A GLOBAL EVENT THAT WILL
FUNDAMENTALLY CHANGE THE
STRUCTURE OF THE WORLD
POLITICAL ORDER, THE WORLD
ECONOMIC ORDER FOR A GENERATION.
THIS IS A HUGE EVENT THAT’S
HAPPENING AND FOR OUR COUNTRY
IT’S VERY IMPACTFUL.
THAT MAKES PARTISAN BICKERING
AND HOT SHOTS AT THIS POINT
TRIVIAL.
WE WILL HAVE TIME LATER ON IN
THE FUTURE TO EXAMINE ALL OF THE
DECISIONS THAT WERE MADE AND
TO FIGURE OUT WHO MADE MISTAKES
SO WE CAN PREVENT IT FROM
HAPPENING AGAIN AND PEOPLE WILL
BE HELD TO ACCOUNT.
NOW IS NOT THAT TIME.
NOW IS THE TIME TO ACT, TO KEEP
THIS FROM BEING WORSE THAN IT
NEEDS TO BE, AND WE CAN’T DO
THAT IF WE SPEND ALL OUR TIME
TAKING POLITICAL SHOTS OR
ARGUING.
BRIAN:  THE THING IS COULD THIS
BE ONE OF THE LAST TIMES
YOU GUYS GET TOGETHER IN THIS
ERA OF SOCIAL DISTANCING
IS IT SAFE FOR THE SENATORS TO
BE PACKED INTO A CHAMBER OR  DO
YOU GUYS HAVE PLANS?
>> WELL THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION
AND I WOULD SAY ABOUT THAT, THE
ARGUMENT I’VE BEEN MAKING
FOR TWO WEEKS NOW IS THAT WE
CANNOT ASSUME THAT WE’RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO OPERATE WITH
BUSINESS AS USUAL.
JUST THINK ABOUT HOW DIFFERENT
THE WORLD LOOKS TODAY THAN JUST
SEVEN DAYS AGO AND I THINK IT
WILL LOOK FUNDAMENTALLY
DIFFERENT SEVEN DAYS FROM NOW
THAN IT DOES TODAY.
WE CANNOT OPERATE HERE UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION WE CAN KEEP
COMING BACK EVERY WEEK AND
PASSING BILLS.
WE’RE GOING TO NEED TO DO AS
MUCH AS WE CAN WHILE WE ARE
HERE BECAUSE WE REALLY DON’T
KNOW WHAT HAPPENS SEVEN, 10, 15
DAYS FROM NOW WE DON’T AND WE
SHOULDN’T PRETEND THAT WE DO AND
WE SHOULD OPERATE UNDER THE
ASSUMPTION THAT WE CAN’T
JUST QUICKLY COME TOGETHER AGAIN
TO ACT.
BRIAN:  HOW DO YOU VOTE?
>> WELL THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION
AND IT’S ONE OF THE ARGUMENTS
ABOUT CONTINUITY OF GOVERNMENT
THAT NEEDS TO BE EXAMINED AND
LOOKED AT.
OUR GOVERNMENT HAS TO CONTINUE
TO OPERATE.
WE’RE NOT GOING TO SUSPECT THE
CONSTITUTION.
WE’RE GOING TO, I BELIEVE THAT
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT NEEDS TO
BE FOCUSED ON BY THE LEADERSHIP
OF THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE IS
HOW CAN CONGRESS CONTINUE TO
OPERATE WHEN A SUBSTANTIAL
NUMBER OF THEIR MEMBERS MAY BE
IN QUARANTINE BECAUSE THEY OR  A
FAMILY MEMBER HAS BEEN INFECTED
OR  BECAUSE THEY FRANKLY CAN’T
GET HERE, BECAUSE OF TRAVEL
ARRANGEMENTS BECOME IMPOSSIBLE.
STEVE: THAT’S RIGHT BECAUSE A
DOZEN MEMBERS OF CONGRESS ARE
SELF-QUARANTINING RIGHT NOW,
NONE HAVE TESTED POSITIVE.
AINSLEY: DO VIDEO CONFERENCING.
THANK YOU SO MUCH SENATOR FOR
BEING WITH US GOOD LUCK